welcome to this video playing Grand
Master Sula Berg Hanson drain you okay
so we got an English opening okay i play
blow with both d4 in 93 yeah it's very
solid line for black can be recommended
if you are looking for a very for
reliable opening against the English
that's not bad at all Bishop hmm age 3 I
mean huh okay maybe I can use the fact
that he's not developed very much trying
to take on f6 damaging his pawn
structure no he's just bring this back
hmm interesting
it doesn't look great you know I mean
it's not developed at all but hmm I
don't know can I can I use this somehow
95 or something and I be five this is
six when I don't really have a great
move then she thinks I don't know
spending too much time is a way to get
in trouble here k h6 I have to go back
it's not I mean if he goes like e six i
have 9 p-5 so it's not so easy for him
to develop stuff g6 okay so i really
have to have to try to use this momentum
move like like before or something as is
this interesting not at the moment i
probably have to get out of those checks
like the night moves Queen checks on the
long diagonal it's a bit lame but maybe
still necessary
so night some night before stuff or
maybe just double handle and the D hell
yeah if he cancels i have 95 it's a
little trick with ed CD ok maybe this is
not really threatening much he was kind
of prepared for the move as we could see
from the relatively quick response song
kicks here Queen takes half night before
winning in the d6 pawn so pawn takes and
now maybe just back here and the ship's
is seven Bishop f4 is good for white
think
so he will play e5 huh what just 94 d5
text x 95 well not sure how good it is
Bishop f4 f5 is a bit weird and it's
it's not necessarily that bad for him
okay so let's do this now it's an
interesting moment here Bishop age 6 is
not going to work
yeah difficult the couple of
good-looking continuations and selecting
one often is not not easy no def 5 is in
the mix and also Queen d5 actually a
Quincy 725 is a move so reason not to
take that I don't see it at the moment
no I don't see it I think I can just
take it
he takes a truck c7 is also completely
deadly pin yeah he had to had to play
that so what now maybe queen of 34 night
at five and Roxy 6 it's prolly in
stronger than Quincy six
so one minute down
yeah position is a real disaster c6
difficult to save even so Knight a5 or
me I can just do this year that's a good
move simple move still sitting on on
those weaknesses so time morning and I
just keep that I then whoop the eight is
a bit shouldn't have done that Luke the
aid is a bit annoying now sd1 is
unprotected I wasn't a 38 was more of a
problem I think
not to a forum so how to win now h form
you're going to do look e 6f six or
something like that nie Dage six is not
leading to much unfortunately but i can
always just go back
maybe I shouldn't shouldn't have gone
for a trade Sam because of the time
objectively speaking this is of course
good just position wise okay nine
subjects are coming
going to cover F tune with the king
should should be pink doable with the
time John I'd c4 was a bit better minute
check check check check check check
check black forfeits on time okay I did
it at the end gambit bit shaky still
yeah it was a very nice position but
don't always get irritated if the time
is some if the time is getting he's he's
moving some some stuff here I don't know
maybe yeah so let's let's have a brief
look around here yeah i mean it that i
also have Bishop f4 that was also
interesting but after 85 he is probably
okay i mean this is weak but how do i
win it i mean like this this is going
here and that's nothing special but
probably this is also not that brilliant
however after this it is right yeah
after that i'm very much in control this
is what the engine is suggesting
yeah that's really good right if i take
it Queen takes my night cannot go here
as I wanted want to do because he has
this protected when I can do this but
oops 32 is of course hanging so it was
much better than than this continuation
and yeah I'm essentially just winning
yeah queen of three I wasn't sure if
this is so great so I was preparing to
go back out this also given by the comp
but now it wants to take c6 yeah
probably it was better i justjust take
another pawn and not go into technical
face already I mean this is nicer and
essentially winning but it was probably
better to take a second phone though now
I'm get to get to trade stuff and this
is really enough because it just not
it's not just the pawn his remaining
structures also really weed with those
two points so i think that was okay from
a technical point a few the only is she
really was that at the time that I had
that I had left okay well thanks for
watching